Dr. Bright is to be consistently reminded
that, if what he is doing involves doing something
wrong?
It is not the right thing to do.
Sure, the Foundation could always use more
funding.
However, that does not mean it is acceptable
for Dr. Bright to organize a massive heist
at a luxury casino, recruiting a variety of
retired criminals to carry out a detailed
multi-step plan of espionage, deception, and
robbery.
It might have worked out in the Ocean’s
film series, but it is not the sort of behavior
the Foundation condones in the real world.
We live in a society, dammit!
There are rules we have to follow!
Sure, we do a great deal of possibly unethical
human testing, resulting in thousands of D-Class
deaths every year, but we have to draw the
line somewhere.